British, normal women that go and shop
in Aldi and collect their children and
do it. They're losing their children
because of you.
>> Firstly, I'm genuinely sorry for what
you went through, sister. But we need to
talk. I'm not your enemy. Because
because because there's a
misunderstanding, sister. I don't want
to harm for you.
Islam Net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in Norway,
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a sadaqa jariya
for you, because every person that comes
a step closer to Allah through your
donation, you will in sha Allah be
written a reward. Click the link and
donate what you can.
Allahu Akbar.
>> Oh, another 100 pounds?
I told you. You see, you know what I
said? Da'wah guy. He wants a picture.
Come come. No, no, no, I want to take a
>> Bunch of [__]
It's a bit harsh. That was I think she
has
I think she has 75 jinn inside her.
That's what it is.
It's the misconception of [__]
>> What's it, madam?
Can I talk?
What's happening, madam?
It's not true, is it? NO. YEAH, WE'RE
NOT PERFECT, but we're not bad people.
We're
we're English, British, normal women
that go and shop in Aldi and collect
their children and do it. They're losing
their children because of you.
>> Who's who's who's YOU, SISTER?
>> YOUR MUSLIM [__] AND THE CORRUPT
[__] that you say.
No, no, no. Brother brother brother
brother. Is she with you?
Can I speak to her?
[__] go. Can I have a conversation?
CAN WE GO? LET ME SPEAK. I already know
I already know what she is.
SHOVE IT UP YOUR ASS AND TELL [__]
WHAT'S-HIS-NAME, HELLO, I said see you
at 10, you [__]
>> Can we speak, sister? Can we speak? Can
we speak? Can we speak?
Sister. Can we speak? Can we talk? Can
we talk? Guys, guys, stop stop guys stop
stop. Can I talk, sister? Can I Can I
Can I Can I Can I TALK, SISTER?
CAN I CAN I CAN I TALK, SISTER?
CAN I CAN I CAN I talk?
CAN I CAN I TALK?
HOW the [__] dare you?
>> Can I speak, sister? Come and speak to
whatever. Can I talk? Making all people,
me.
>> Can I talk, sister?
>> I'm British. I'm Lou. Am I British? Am I
British?
Am I Am I British, sister?
I never ASKED FOR ANYTHING. MY MOM WAS A
[__] SHE LEFT ME. She had parents and I
was a prisoner. I was left in the care
I'm sorry. I'm sorry to say that,
sister.
>> So, WHERE WAS ALLAH IN THAT?
>> I KNOW, SISTER, but I'm saying So, where
does Allah leave PEOPLE LIKE ME THAT I'M
ASKING YOU?
You asking for people to be forgiveness
that Can I talk?
>> Where is mine?
>> talk, sister? Look at Where is it? Can I
talk, sister? I'm sorry that you went
through that, sister, but
I'm genuinely sorry what you went
through, sister.
Can I reply, sister?
Okay. Okay. Firstly, firstly, I'm
genuinely sorry for what you went
through, sister. But we need to talk.
I'm not your enemy. Because because
because there's a misunderstanding,
sister. I don't want to harm for you.
Okay, do you want to
>> No, you don't, but you can't stop. But
can I Can I Can I talk, sister? On any
level, Christian. Can I Can I Can I Can
I talk, sister? All these people that
evil. You don't understand that you're
good. Yes. That's what I'm saying,
sister. Your role is not to go blah blah
blah. Your role is just to go and tell
the people the little kids my kids I've
got five I've got three daughters. I've
got three daughters. Whatever happened
I've got three daughters. Be kind and
that's what I want to say. My sister,
I've got I've got No, no, I'm sorry. I'm
I'm I'm sorry.
But But hear me out, sister. Hear me
out.
But hear me out, sister. I've got three
daughters. I've got three daughters.
It's wrong and it's causing so much.
Sister, I've got three daughters. I've
got an 8-year-old, I've got 4-year-old
and a 2-year-old. Okay?
I just tell them one thing. Okay. Yes.
One thing we have, one thing
kind. Just one word I say to my
daughters to anyone, just be kind. I
always say it and I'm the biggest wallet
Just be kind.
>> Yes. Same sentence about what makes you
think that we Muslims are the like Do
you No, I don't think. I don't think and
whatever it is but I'm not saying
Whatever it is.
Yeah. No, no, no, 100%.
Yeah, yeah. No, no.
I'm not practicing but I get like a week
off work.
Yeah.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. I've seen so many people and I
give it in every situation. My nephew's
become a Muslim. I've got five children.
Your nephew's become Muslim? Yeah, my
nephew has. Do you know anything about
Islam, sister? Do you know anything
about Islam? Not really. Sister, let me
put it like this. You There's a big
misconception and a lie being spread.
I'm not your enemy. I have I have a
family like you. I have kids like you.
Can we slow it down? Sorry. Okay. I Can
Can we just like Can we like I'm Louise.
Yeah. Nice meeting you, Ali. Nice
meeting you, sister. Yeah, out of
respect we don't shake Out of respect we
don't shake hands. But that's cuz I
respect you. I'm not shaking my hand.
Please. That's cuz you know
But you know what? I I I I respect you.
I think everything, innit?
Hello.
God sees you.
He understands your pain. Yeah, it's
good to see you.
You're good Muslim. I know I'm not
alone.
So So So we believe we believe we
believe in God, sister. We We believe
believe that God is one. Spread the
word. Spread the good word. Yeah, we
are. We are. Spread the word that
everyone is equal.
There are There are There You're not
spreading the word. We are. We are.
You're not spreading a It's kind of like
narrative like a If you do this, then
you will be No. That's That's
Christians. We don't say that. We don't
say that.
We don't say that, sister. Christians
say that. Christians do me to hell. We
don't do that. We believe God is all
merciful. Christians say if you don't do
that, you go to hellfire.
We We believe We believe God is the most
merciful and he's merciful to his
servants and he wants a relationship. I
I believe there's one God and we're here
to Allah.
Yeah.
Do you know what that means? But Allah
means God.
So So So what I mean is this, sister.
That's a lot of kind of like person in
the running. And I don't think they
really know who the person is. But you
know what? I think everyone just running
for the same thing. But do you agree
that people at the top want us to fight
each other? And we're we're we're a
family. You have a family. Thank you.
People like Tommy Robinson. You know
Tommy Robinson? Yeah, I do. People like
him, look, he is he is now in Israel and
he's Yes, you don't but he's putting an
another country before Britain. And he
says he's a patriot. He says he's a
patriot. He's out there. He's been
humiliated by the Israelis. He's been
paid by them and he's putting me and you
against each other when we should not
Look, babe. Yes. I'm a I'm a proper
Brit. I'm Lou. That's good. That's good.
On the On the absolute word of God, I'm
a dad. I was a schizophrenic. My mom was
an alcoholic. I've I've lived with the
Albanians, the whatever. I am a true
true whatever, but one thing I will say
in it
>> Yes, sister.
We are one. Thank you. At the end of it
all, but the thing is when all the
parents
>> Yes. No, no, you don't. What's your
name?
>> Ali. Ali. Can I tell you something? My
name is Ali Louise. Nice meeting you,
sister.
>> Can you listen to me and you might be
the only person I am Louise, yeah, and I
was brought up in care. My mom was a
drug addict and an alcoholic. When I was
10 years old, I was the same. And when I
went into children's home, I met so many
people from all different backgrounds,
but you know one thing we had in common?
Was that we just wanted to be loved. And
we came as a unit and then all the war
broke out and it was
It's not right. I know. I know. I agree.
>> It's not true.
It's not No, you don't.
I want to eat your mic.
Let's talk, sister.
>> Because No, it ain't. Just Look at the
chief or stop [__] because you don't
know. Do you know? No.
Have you Have you Have you read the
Quran? Have you read the Quran? I don't
want to read the Quran.
I don't agree with any of it.
I appreciate it. But hopefully, sister
Yes, humanity.
Yeah, of course.
Oh, yeah.
You together?
Yeah.
No, no, it's okay. It's okay, you know.
What's your What's your name?
What's your name?
Nice meeting you, Hayden. You're right.
Yeah, it's a pleasure.
I think I think she's a good heart. No,
no, she is. She doesn't even know what
yours
She doesn't have too much to drink.
It's totally fine. You don't have to say
anything. She is good, yeah.
You here for the weekend or Uh we live
like in
It's fine. I'm all right. I'm saying
That's good. Nice Nice
NICE YOU DON'T GET NORMAL people who are
actually true and believe in the [__]
I'm a normal person. I've been there.
I've walked Do you believe Do you
believe the government makes us try to
go against each other?
I believe in Do you believe that? I
believe in that. I believe in that.
I believe in that. Ali Ali I don't know
if you Do you know what I believe?
I don't know what you believe. I was
born into a schizophrenic. I believe in
human nature. My best friend and
kindness. Kindness. I had a friend that
was Iranian.
And she was in war and her family Yeah,
we are. You know what?
I knew her for 6 weeks and my mom
stopped me from seeing her, but We were
like I know it sounds I put my friend
he's like oh, you're such an idiot. We
were best friends and she said to me
when I go home, I'm going to be killed
and I loved her so much. I'm so sorry to
hear that. No, no, but what I'm saying
is
You can't choose or whatever, but you
can choose who you want to be. And But
do you see how destructive alcohol is,
sister? That's why in Islam we believe
alcohol, gambling These things are
destructive. That's why we believe Islam
has come Islam has come to preserve
human life. And look how alcohol has
destroyed your mom and that's the ripple
effect on you. No, not really. Alcohol
just made me want to be a better You
know what I'm trying to say?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. So So
But it was It was It was nice talking to
you. Thank you sister. It was really
nice talking to you. But yeah, I I I
hope you you know He knows. Look at him
smiling. You're a bad son. Yeah, it was
nice talking to you sister. Would you
like a free Quran? No. Not really no.
Okay, but it was nice talking. I hope
you like the suffering that you went
through. I'm genuinely sorry. I'm sorry.
>> I'll be the one I'll be the one in the
I'm sorry that you had to go through
that but believe me if you leave Islam,
Islam will change your life for the
better. I promise you. I promise you
give Islam a chance and Islam will
change you for the better sister.
Believe me.
>> then? I I I I became a Muslim 13 years
ago.
Look look I used to come clubbing and
partying here. I I became I became
Muslim 13 years ago. I know I don't look
Muslim. I don't know what that looks
like. But I came to Islam 13 years ago.
It changed my life for the better.
Alcohol, gambling, sex before marriage.
I gave I used to come clubbing and
partying in the street every week.
Every week I used to come clubbing and
partying here.
You know what? Let me tell you
something. Now I have purpose. I don't
need alcohol.
>> Oh, what do you do then? Uh well, I'm
here. I used to do Uber
until COVID came and I lost I lost I
lost my job. Yeah. But but yeah, it was
it was it was it was nice. Yeah, yeah.
But it was nice talking to you sister.
Sister Louise, it was nice talking to
you. But yeah, sister
Yeah. Yeah, it was it was nice talking
to you and do do give the Quran a
chance. Can I give you one? Please. Let
me give it to you. Read it. You got
nothing to lose. I don't want to give my
money. A Quran free Quran. Sheikh, do we
have a free Quran? Sheikh, do we have a
free Quran?
Sheikh, do we have a free Quran?
Oh, there we go. There we go. Sister
Louise, this is from us. Please read it
and it will change your life. Okay.
Okay, it was lovely talking to you. Have
a nice day. Look after yourself.
Please read it though. Please read it.
Okay, thank you sister. Thank you. No,
but what is No, one thing I will say
Quran or not or Sorry sorry for that for
that.
Okay, if I do that I'll get in trouble.
I'll get in big trouble. Yeah.
Yeah, but try try try. Do you know what?
Just from that state of saying I'm
speaking
>> No no no but but sister look look look
imagine imagine I hug I can't touch you.
I'm hugging you. I'm speaking to you. No
no I know I know I know I'm just saying.
It was for hugging mate. No no no. I was
hugging you.
I was hugging you. I understand I
understand I understand. But but give
the Quran a chance sister. Yeah, okay.
Yeah.
Read it. I appreciate it. Read it
inshallah. Thank you. Thank you sister.
Thank you.
Okay, all right. Okay guys,
alhamdulillah. As you can see from
sister, this is why it's so important
for us to be here.
You heard it for yourself alhamdulillah
subhanallah. Different people go through
different stuff in life alhamdulillah
and it's really sad because you know
why? The people at the top are trying to
get us to fight each other.
Alhamdulillah us being here on the
ground, it's important for us to spread
this message because even if you change
one heart, you don't know what that can
do inshallah.